what would you say
is the most fascinating
terrifying surprising beautiful virus to
you so
of all the viruses you looked at
sometimes when you just sit late at
night with a glass of wine looking over
the sunset which virus do you think
about
so
fulfilling all of those adjectives is
hard
right fascinating
exciting terrifying well the terrifying
is an optional one i think because
maybe that puts a lot of pressure i see
terrifying
to me
i'm not terrified because i think we can
handle
as most viruses as you see with this
brand new one that emerged a year ago
where we can handle it
from a virology perspective yeah i mean
the human perspective is a different
story right that's always an issue but
um
so i i think
are a couple of different
categories of virus so we could do the
the terrifying and i think rabies is a
terrifying virus because unless you're
vaccinated
certainty you're going to die
so you get bitten by a rabid raccoon or
bat or dog whatever
and you know and
there's still 70 000
deaths a year of rabies throughout the
world because there are a lot of feral
dogs running around that are infected
unless you're vaccinated you're going to
die there's nothing we can do but we do
have a vaccine which we can actually
give you
even after you've been bitten which is
the only
vaccine that works that way it's a
therapeutic right it will treat your
illness because the disease takes so
long to develop
you know eventually you get all kinds of
neurological issues and
paralysis and so forth but it takes time
and you can be vaccinated it will
prevent that in the meanwhile so people
always say what's the most lethal virus
is it ebola i said no it's actually
rabies it unless you're vaccinated it
will kill you
maybe it's good to linger because we'll
talk about vaccines a few times today
it's good to linger
on cases where vaccines have clearly
uh
undoubtedly helped human civilization
and it seems like uh rabies is a good
example oh rapist is great because
everyone knows what happens when
somebody gets rabies right
you have fear of water
hydrophobia
your body becomes and stiff and
jerks around and
you lose consciousness you can't
no no more not a fun ride to death it's
horrible it's a horrible way to die
so i think most people know that it's
been popularized enough in in media
right so that nobody would probably
object to getting
oh i was just bit by this raccoon and it
ran off
okay well we should assume it's rabid we
should immunize you and most people are
okay with that yeah because they know
the consequences and it's also pretty
rare
right it's not like something that
you're trying to get into the arms of
you know
three 250 300 million americans that's
hard but the the the the few thousand
every year is easy so the
transmissibility is difficult right it
has to
oh it's not it's not airborne so now
you're bored it just has to be you have
to be bitten although some some people
claim you could
walk into a cave
and the bats you know breathing out
rabies virus could infect you but i
don't really think that's well that's
well substantiated yeah i think it's a
bite how would you do a study on that
yeah it's very hard to do you'd have to
collect the vapors in the cave and show
that they're infectious which and by the
way
someone emailed me the other day you'll
like this they say why can't we just
immunize all the bats in the world
against these viruses and i said well
how would you do that there's caves
everywhere right yeah
he said well maybe you could just go and
aerosolize that
yeah it's pretty dangerous and then and
then all the bats should have vaccine
passports to make sure that they're yeah
so you have to get their consent before
you do it
but
you we do
immunize wildlife against rabies
we have rabies vaccines for wild animals
there are a whole bunch of them that get
rabies
and we put it we put it in bait and drop
it from helicopters in the woods and it
drops down the incidence of uh rabies
and people wow you know people hiking
get bitten and so forth it drops the
incident so we can do that i didn't know
that i always wondered how much medical
care we're doing for animals in the wild
because
i've recently become more and more aware
that animals are living in extreme
poverty
right like you don't know you think like
natural it's great
um you know like uh like when animals
are living on a farm it's terrible but
then you also have to compare to like
what life is like and or like the zoo
you have to compare what life is like in
in the wild well life in the wild is
very tough i think i mean most animals
have to well the carnivores anyway they
have to catch their food every day yeah
right and then there's the viruses there
they have viruses as well so the rabies
immunization is the only
one i'm aware of for wild animals um
we do immunize lots of other
animals we immunize
chickens and pigs and cows
even fish farmed fish we
pick each fish up and give it an
injection you know when it's a small
fish
but that's mostly
so that the farmers get a good yield we
don't really care about the animals
right we want a good yield for
market and then there's some examples
where we
immunize animals to prevent
spillovers into people
so there's a disease called hendra in
australia
which
was
discovered in the 90s it turns out that
there are bats fruit bats that have this
virus the bats are fine
but sometimes they're flying into horse
stalls
and the horses get infected these are in
australia was initially race horses
which are very expensive right
the horses got infected and they died
and the humans who would take care of
them would die also so now they immunize
the horses
to prevent the well to save the horses
probably that's the motivation because
these horses are hundreds of thousands
of dollars right and then the people
don't get sick because the horses don't
get sick you don't want to immunize all
the people because it's too rare but
that approach is called one world health
approach which means everything's
connected on the planet
and we have to think of everything in
the grander scheme not just us
yes you can immunize some things along
the trajectory that a virus would take
exactly so something some living beings
yeah in the arabian peninsula they have
a mers coronavirus issue every month
there are a couple of cases where a
camel will infect the human and the
human can get very sick
it's respiratory disease very very much
like covid
and so
camels are very common there they're
used they're raced they're used as pets
they're eaten
so there's a lot of human camel contact
but the number of cases are rare two to
a month so you don't want to immunize
all the humans so the idea would be to
immunize the camels
so i like it so okay so you put rabies
but ebola
uh also is a
famously deadly one right what is it it
kills like i don't know 50 60 percent of
it could be 50 to 90 but
that's in africa where the health care
isn't great what you saw when they when
cases of ebola came to the u.s
we were we could take care of it we knew
how to take care of we had fancy
hospitals and so forth and now we have a
vaccine so
we can and the vaccine is really good
but there are many governments in africa
who that are suspicious of of us and
they don't want to use our vaccines so
they so there's a vaccine for ebola
there is yeah and uh
the effectiveness and safety of it to
how much is understood so
this is difficult because there's not a
lot of ebola right
it's not a continuous ongoing thing
there are sporadic outbreaks here and
there of a few thousand people at most
at most usually a few hundred and the
biggest ever
in fact this is why we didn't for years
have an ebola vaccine the us military
together with canada developed an ebola
vaccine for service people right they
wanted to say well we're sending people
into these ebola areas we want a vaccine
for them so they had developed it
through
all the pre-clinical which means before
it goes into people
and that stopped because there was no
money to do a phase one and a phase two
and a phase three in fact for phase two
and three you need to have infections
going on because you're looking at how
well the vaccine prevents infections
right so then there was a west african
outbreak in 2015
2013 2015. the most cases ever 25 000 so
they got to test the vaccine um but
they only put it in a few thousand
people it's not like it's been in
hundreds of thousands of people like the
covid vaccines has been so
it's it looks like it's it has high
efficacy
but we'd like to have more data
side effects may be are not so great
there are a couple of different
available vaccines some have been tested
more than others
i would say
this would probably not be widely
accepted in the u.s
but then
neither would be
something over 50
uh deadliness of a virus no i think if
you were in fact many physicians work in
countries that have ebola so they get
vaccinated because they understand the
choice yeah right it's always about the
choice um so
so then one more thing to answer the
interesting
what are some of the viruses you really
are fascinated by
there are a number of viruses that
have clearly been shown to alter host
behavior and that's how they spread
i think those are fascinating for
example
there are some viruses of plants
that are spread by aphids
and the aphid bites the plant the virus
reproduces in the plant and it somehow
engineers the plant to give off volatile
organics
to attract more aphids
which will spread the virus
isn't that amazing
yeah so that's altering the behavior
altering because somehow the virus
infecting the plant cells gives off
these organics and interacts aphids and
furthermore
somehow the when the aphid bites it
tastes horrible so they immediately
leave with the virus they've just picked
up and go to another plant to spread it
so they're attracted and then repulsed
at the same time and obviously you don't
want to anthropomorphize this like a
strategy they're taking on somehow this
worked out it worked out this way it
just evolved and you know evolution is
sometimes hard to trace right
like
darwin famously said he could never
figure out how an eye evolved from a
single cell right but
it did
the more complicated complex the the
holistic organism is that the virus
invades
the less able it is to control that
organism right so i wonder if there's
viruses that can control human behavior
um
you know to
induce
more spread of the virus
well i don't see why not there's not
enough humans i supposed to like evolve
through well we can't do the experiment
to test it right we have to observe and
that's always hard when you're observing
because there's so many things that can
confound
what you're looking at change human
behavior yeah i mean there's so many
things that impinge on our behavior but
um yeah it's i think it's possible um i
think it's highly possible if it does it
in a plant why not change some other
organism's behavior i think it's fine
anyway those fascinate me there are lots
of examples of those
that are fascinating and how they work
people are trying to figure out but
there's not a lot of money to work on
you know insect and plant viruses unless
you're going to the usda so they don't
get a lot of
work moving forward well is there if you
understand some of those viruses is that
transferable to human viruses that
understanding i think some of it could
be sure i think the general principles
for example how the
how does the virus cause volatile
organics to be made it must be
turning on some genes
and you could learn principles from that
how the virus might do that sure i think
everything is broadly applicable to so
to say
it's not useful to study
viruses of insects and plants is just
wrong because in science you probably
know this maybe in your field it's the
same
if you're curious you're going to run
into interesting things that you never
planned on right that's why people like
you can criticize why do we want to go
on mars why do we want to colonize mars
well it's like why do you want to go to
the moon
the the reality is when you do really
difficult things
yeah engineering things like all these
inventions along the way are created
it's kind of fascinating how basically
just
pick a
pick a thing that everyone can agree is
kind of cool and it's really hard and do
that and then you'll have like thousands
of inventions that have nothing to do
with the thing that's right i think you
should let
curious scientists just follow what
they're interested in to a certain
extent you can't
you know in science we say we have
translational research where we say okay
here's some money go cure cancer or
diabetes or heart disease whatever right
and that's fine but that often doesn't
work out very well what works better is
to say here you're you have a good lab
you have a good track record here's some
money
or something and that's where pcr
crispr recombinant dna all that stuff
which has made the field explode that's
all it came from not from people saying
i want to cure genetic diseases by gene
editing but by saying what are these
repeated things in this bacterium doing
yeah
you